French meeting with this load of meat, general
turkey zit ya Say S4
[Music]
My name is Mahmut, this is where we are now
Özkonak Custard is the pain that doesn't want
to prosper, Sheikh Efendi is calm for the word his Hunter
charming printshop By the way, the project
specializes in is Stick chest year
soreal  shape restory this goes
back to the Ottoman period Maybe
a chicken breast from that period
slowly, others here are sweets
Baklava with milk as their products as chicken
breast we are keeping it alive today
chicken breast itself is
a very meat that changes a lot of effort I
made it this way  Well, sorry, sir,
I did it right away.
Friends,
when you take a water spoon,
you say that you make me taste like this. Look, you don't say how
beautiful the chicken is.
But it's a good food source, see
you, amazing
people Very good this year
Yes, now let's admit it like this in a
week At least 20  27 14 again,
there are a hundred or so, and he finds 100-150.
The customer said to us very well, good luck to you,
but we are also happy,
why do we do our headlights with love, make it a
family Then we
stayed until this period, I hope we will
continue
it from now on, subscribe to it
[Music]